[Music]
welcome back to fox and friends former
acting secretary of defense christopher
miller is joining calls for general mark
milley to resign over accusations he had
secret phone calls with china miller
telling fox news quote i did not and
would not ever authorize such conduct
meanwhile president biden is standing
behind the general saying general milley
has great he has great confidence in
general milley retired army general
brigadier general i should say don
baldick uh joins us now uh general who's
right here general jack keane who said
uh to fox yesterday he takes military's
word and called his actions responsible
or
so many others
i i believe his actions are
irresponsible and they fall somewhere
between treason and dereliction of duty
we never would tolerate that in our
subordinate officers we would remove
them immediately lieutenant colonel
sheller lieutenant colonel lowe meyer
our recent examples
this is uh i am being reached out to by
many people in the military who have
lost confidence in the chairman uh
there's a perception out there that he
did this
he needs to
do the right thing
have some moral courage step aside
we need to conduct an investigation and
he needs to be held accountable for this
either treasonous or somewhere between
dereliction of duty general you know uh
joe biden in the white house say
we stand by general milley but if
general milley did this to joe biden you
got to figure
he probably would be fired by noon
oh there there would be no doubt that
president trump would have fired him uh
i i would assume it wouldn't take until
noon time right
and rightly so this is a loss of
confidence i mean how many times are we
going to lose confidence in this guy
first of all we have a border security
situation which the military has
tremendous responsibility and our border
security is is failing right now the
withdrawal in afghanistan was a disaster
the policy military strategy leading up
to the withdrawal was a disaster and now
we have these phone calls to
counterparts i talked to many of my
counterparts as a you know division
level commander special operations
command africa and never would it have
entered my mind to make any comments
like this we have to develop those
relationships they're necessary but this
if true
is uh treasonous or at at the least
dereliction of duty that's what
president trump said too uh he said if
it is true it's treason i know that
you've called for milly's resignation
many times you say that you know how he
operates as a politically driven general
what do you mean by that
well i've watched him over the years and
i've watched many of the generals and
most of the joint chiefs that are in
place right now they changed their
colors you know a lot of them started
off with george bush transitioned over
to
uh president obama and you know bought
off on all the all the all the bad
policy in africa afghanistan iraq syria
uh all over the you know all over the
world that weakened america's position
with their allies then they transitioned
uh to president trump uh which i knew
would be difficult for all of them
apparently it has because they
undermined him behind his back
and then they go back to president biden
who has demonstrated how
it's an incompetent administration and
we are in a lot of trouble economically
fiscally in the safety and security of
americans and i am afraid for our
reputation and for our military service
members on the ground in many places of
the world now if you're afraid then
we're afraid but the good news is that
china's going to get a heads up if we're
going to bomb them so that's good to
know uh that that war college class is
going to be in session uh appreciate it
general uh and we we hear your alarm
well i hope americans do and i hope they
call for him to do the right thing i
know our service members believe there's
a perception perception can be reality
it's one of the rules of a leader and if
you're if you're not operating
effectively and you're hurting your
organization you need to step aside all
right general thank you very much thanks
for your service general
god bless you all thank you
indeed